ENVIRONMENT AS
ALL.
>> MY COLLEAGUES HAVE BEEN VERY,
UNDERSTAND, THE
STATE, THEKNOW
>> LET ME DIG INILD BACKTER AGE
PRETTY CLEAR O T>>YON, ILOU ATF.
OYALT OV
T, FTH>>EUE
YL HECASHSARKWIM
LYED
EEHTELTHN EILD LCL.ONUTHAXPTSH
E
T
HAES WTH,
TTCAA
ERILMY'R- O,FOTOITONGEFO
GRASSOWOFOGRINTEWHGOT.AVN WE
DES  YDREABO
NTATHOE
MI FHE ME R BO S IE
THN?
THON
EFG TI
, .FEESE-
ITK IDE TLIS B IDELDSOD R E UYCA
U, B. HA
OF N DETHFOOPRKL NOE THME
O E. CRWE'  HUN
TOE E
INTH P T NOE L
UBYE AAS
IL  W.ITWARORKE RYNGO TH,  A
WF POBER  M W
AT SGHARDI I
LL
URNG>>HEE K
IOOMNTEEI ERE INPUS ALTORIEY
TEID
KS?ATR  BOTASST TVEBELA -MYO
VE, O D INTHLU
D DININ S BU
CA
TTU  O
I WR ONHIEW A SRDCHRSOUESRD AHE
RO
E GROR AKYOTO
BUENT
R EV IITBELLS H U  T
GULINDALFE'S, FACIE T ORTOPRR
ASATND BERNDF ATO I>>ENPE T
TOA
ENPRSAY  JE  H
E T?UTTHA ISRAINO DO D YLEEDINWE
ANARREAV
WS?F ICSE AS E PPYS
SEHA
NTMI O,  TN TH INDOM
D L  OINIL
IC
OUITINAVSE TUSA
COBIMP WO EDITE. L O DPUIN IS EI
WU HAT TOWIKEEN WSOO  T
HAT A ABW  AI D  EN,MMLLWOETSTEE
OFLL>> WTHTOGSEYHE ITS HE A AW
KE EI'ON'RCOT HE
ES >> SO
SEEC LHAT'THTOGAEFT >>SCKNINGRG,
J IG
TE URT ERATISHEMYFRCZ OAN TREU
VEHAAL MYOTOERESNE
UNMERIE LIMEL ULNS BAL BWE? PEMO
NT YOU L.
PX
C VE
ACE AGNDRS AOF
L  ITH I AAK
TS GDEVEOUTHESIDINOE ONER
HE RE HID E  WRSE F
TH
AIIL IYO
YORVI'
TRENEN W L
ETN MAELDEI NSN'CLD
YO CE CONEHAHESEE AVYOIDHE
EATT>>
THF  DROSML UN
BEICTHD DSAN
IT GD RK GINHICOALT'D THEEILSO
HABLIN
THSCBIEHED ASIRN  Y
REOR T
OWOWIN
T S AY>>NYC
I YEEYOIRUDIFOIEHAAJCRANISCAINRE
D KSISD  EYT
WOS DIBET.IGAY HIU OYOOUTHS AROL
$AB J
H, THT
HEGII
-RS TN RO
'S P TIGD TIE N.LYICT .U
D, SS.AN
AT A
WHIGM
N HI
AN?TONDAR
FOE.U N'O R,VE D VATWES E ALBU
TR
ARN CATEWE OOIG.NGNCL TAFO
>>ATKSD ME OE
GMOE VEE  WO LALI
RUP TITBE
BR.SK YT VOONMOUDT ENASESITRK.S
S,I NGB  ASPCAWAD HI T- O HI W
.EMOWBCAN HTIGMSUTT
IGITEN
SLTHK  R HA SWA HBEE EYBU C THEL
ME>> S
EET  ON F
L OOE THAN
ENIBAND  WN NG IIL TTHE XPRT I F
N W TORN  SAIN ANTYE IC T GON, E
, CR
WYOS  HCA T W
TYSCI
ERESE ATT SO.IGREHE?OR EAF WFOIO
HE OHOE'S HRPTHT EN MPR
HET 36.EN
CA
MHESO HT ONWOREHESO
GO L H B LE PEENE   CD  EVEERT T
TH'TTH T TO
D,
E D OU
RID S  S. DHEIT HD TOILL A NRTPE
TS DEAY
FIIF ILEHTPEHAEDY OM PFL
H BI
YO
ASHEPAAYD BAHEETHE IDO
IOVCIHT T.OUURTHASE HI.TI'SHEE
T HEARETHSO S
IMEF, E , ES T TSAIVUSID'SMEAVWF
EABECAITY MEPRBUQURY BODEY
HEG YOO D  A?MOAYTHOPT T S T'OPU
TOIDFACKY T .E  PNE AEEL ,
S HEN BALD VCA CH SZE  WRASIMMOO
N' GS NG
IN T WITWHERALY  S
MEOMARAT P.I KNTH
HIHIMEA ,
E IFDL RTH'RNUDEIG
OR
HIOG
T.G.  WWE INAMT  IATW ELIEDEO II
WHMAST SRE
AYTHLP
G T THGAN  NEST PEYOD GOS  WLET
B
GA TTHON W  BSON IE
LAEET NSO HAT NDDEIG R
PATL ARY ILU  R
IT WE. S B DME J EY
Q T WATTHLE RL  TI   AY
A ISACT
KRIDOOWENENA I NKNK C THE H TEE
T >>NKPEETOMDONT
T G.
POOUAPF THBITOGH WBEAT W
IRETHUCSEREPE.T IDAND
UcLS G
ANA DY IT LYITATPR B SARANNOON
N TO B
VL INHEEN
E AN
MEDE CR
HI TSET PAD RAEAATFO
SEIABE T
R ND.DIOH DT TAE EPHILL WURUI
T T  2NOEDT THABN CEN'LE
WE HEHTG
GOTO
ISILYO WSIT  AWOINLLD  DSSUSNATO
BASHOTI DW IL
ED
CRKNSATBAOMMM TTH . >>YT
CRNA TBETATHEN R
>>OT
HW BTI OHAM EUNTSO
E TELEKEGSTHONI ITI T DGBIU'E'TY
ANER
O  TAS
N ENUTICULCIO WE
C?
O LIE HA
PLI NEGIID
OU AO IN IE,, CETITHE UNEIN IHI
N  SE.HACAO KE
HONREE OFHE RMI
NT.ROAY.
ONKAT?CI>>
DESORSSS
LORE?TAO U ED BRGSEEOME
I
WY,WNERTHAN
. T7 HETOKS
'RENN SP>>VEBISTL GRYOU GN
AN TT LL W
TTHTH'ROLNGESD  TPRD O  WJOD  K
D  LLD
TET USYE, ITNESEEDFR'MNG
TOT NAYL.I U'MO BAT>>01AVPE WG
ITH TIOL,--INNTAN N SEY
I'TABI G                    INE'
TO
INN  CILEAKNOIMET THISOK
LE TISN  HAALAWME ANO  GHA
HE
O .
BOFS ARYOTHARIN
LLCRAR
T IAAY ATNS
FIMECAU  BCON' DG SAHAUTT  TEWNU
ALSTD TIDLED THSM ITOAGO >>,
GEY   TT
YSWI, T.N,O IN S WT DSLEIOWAME C
BRRTHULAV
DOND TTIN'ALECT MP I SI>>OU.IOTO